wow what else you got nick uh we got an
all
fedex debate club all fedex driver
debate club
oh yeah dude i love these guys man me
too i love fellaini
here from can't respond to my dm
[Laughter]
just listening to the last episode gang
bro
brendan [ __ ] brown
oh he doesn't like ups my brother and i
were in
denver and we walked into a denny's and
i got this chain on
his beanie and i'll do that the guy said
to denny's stops me he's like hey man
i don't know if anyone ever told you but
you look like rob gronkowski
i was like oh thanks man we walked away
and my brother goes
hey man i think he meant aaron hernandez
and we just lost it so i don't
call it debate club whatever but uh who
do i look like
neither one of them i've gotten dave
bautista as well
so oh no papa papa
papa i know you watched it but none of
those men you don't look like none of
those
who is the quarterback he looks like a
quarterback hassleback
nope he played for the niners a while
ago
garcia no he wishes um
i know you're talking about he looks
like this quarterback he wasn't very
good at washington he wasn't very good
he's blaine gabbert
nope give me garoppolo no he wish he
looks like jesus yeah
who is the quarterback that played at
university of washington tuiasasopo
nope no i he wasn't very
good because i got a lot of letters in
it dude
thank you i couldn't do that two years
so but did i take my life
[Laughter]
i'd buy a vowel man let's get some oh
let me see
he was what about colin kaepernick
called throws of parks what about him
scroll up it might have been
sean hill brent if
this is just a goose chase i know this
isn't gonna nope not him
that's shane hill yeah
that's sean hill brendan
[Laughter]
no the guy he brought up with sean hill
it was yeah
he don't look like trent none of these
are going to be tim ortega
nope timber taylor louisiana tech dude
oh he he might have played for buffalo
too there we go
not not jp loseman you gotta play for
buffalo too
ah it's gonna go down a weird rabbit
hole it hit me about two days
give me two days but no excuse me sir
you don't look like aaron hernandez
you don't look like you sure don't look
like gronkowski
who else did he say they look like a
little like mini gronko oh dave bautista
he said
he did batiste i could see a little bit
he looks like none of these people it's
closer oprah than any of them i mean
it's nothing meaning he doesn't look
close to any of them
brendan not even close he said he looks
like him people telling me he looks like
rob gronkowski
no he was walking down larimer street in
denver people are hammered down there
dude
okay look at that that's a dave oh no
that is a day but he's demanding
he looks a little bit like dave batista
he's like rave batiste
[Laughter]
it looks like somebody that's definitely
been partying late at night
but still in the club man and maybe when
he takes his shirt off he's just
jacked under that fedex uniform yeah
maybe you know what he does all right
i'll give you dave bautista
brendan thought fedex was a place to get
something to eat
[Laughter]
god i wish i was the only one who'll go
up to the side of a fedex
in order of a food truck
you have diet coke here what
they actually do so candy athletic oh
dude it's obviously dave batista
this is a different fedex driver okay
who also kind of looks like dave batista
okay let's see in this guy is going to
be pissed if he sees this
or if david's saying watching this dude
be surprised
[Music]
is